-Adam, welcome.
Thank you so much.
[ Mimicking applause ]
Fake audience.
-Oh, thank you, thank you.
-Yeah.
I'm so happy
that you're on my show.
Thank you so much because I get
to congratulate you,
kind of, over Zoom.
Congratulations on being engaged
to be married.
-Oh, thanks, Jimmy.
I appreciate it, yeah.
-Did the quarantine put a stop
to the planning at all?
-Well, neither of us
are, like, huge planners.
So, we kind of didn't
start planning
until the quarantine hit
and we're like, "We should
probably get on this."
And then realized that, like,
everything is pushed
like a solid year and a half.
So now, I didn't want
to be involved
with any of the planning.
I wrote a post to Chloe saying,
"Look, we got engaged,"
and in the post I wrote,
"Have fun planning the wedding.
I'll see you
at the cake tasting,"
and everyone is like,
"That's cute."
And I'm like, "That's real."
I plan on not being involved.
-[ Laughs ]
"I'm just gonna show up."
-Yeah, I'm like, "I'm just here,
put on the tux, I do."
And now there's
no getting around it
because she'll be like, "What do
you think of these flowers?"
and I can't be like, "I'm busy."
And she's like,
"You're not busy.
You're watching season six
of 'The Sopranos.'"
-[ Laughs ]
-Which is good.
-Which is great, by the way.
I want to get into
all these things because --
I want to get into "Bad Ideas"
because I think --
Has your confidence
increased now
because of your show that's on
Quibi, "Bad Ideas"?
Like, now that you want --
You're like a daredevil now?
-Yeah.
It's a weird thing.
It's definitely kind of stuff
that in my normal regular life
I would never do.
We went up the Amazon
and I swam with piranhas,
and we drove -- I drove a truck
on one of the world's
most dangerous roads,
things that I normally
wouldn't do.
There's definitely an element
of danger to the show that,
in hindsight, I was like, "Oh,
uh, maybe if we do a season 2,
I'm a little more cautious."
-Yeah, you're like, "I've never
had a fried egg before.
That would be
kind of cool, right?
That's a bad idea."
-It's a bad idea.
-"This is not gonna
be good at all
if I eat two
of these McMuffins."
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
"I'm a wild man. Indigestion.
Kill me now."
-Dude, "Wild Man with
Adam Devine" is another one.
That's a different show.
-Yeah, how many fruit I can eat
out of this fruit tray.
-Oh, man, he's nuts!
No spoilers.
-"He's wild,
and he's dipping it in yogurt!
This guy's insane!"
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
"Can I show this on TV?"
-Too much dairy.
-Did you end up getting hurt
at all doing these things?
-I did -- Yeah, so, I did one
with Blake Anderson
from "Workaholics."
And we did a demolition derby,
and that one was nuts, Jimmy,
'cause I didn't know how --
They, like, literally taught us
how to drive stick, like,
right before we get in
this demolition derby.
So, we did one that was like
a double decker where two cars
that are, like, welded on
top of each other.
And Blake was in charge
of the gas and the brakes
and I was in charge
of the steering.
And we were doing great.
But then we -- it was like --
we're in first place
and really, for whatever reason
this just worked
for the two of us,
but you couldn't hear,
so we're screaming.
I'm like, "Brake, brake!"
and he's like, "Gas?"
And we took a corner
too quickly.
-The opposite of brake. It
doesn't even rhyme with brake!
-It doesn't even sound close!
And we flipped over,
and I was at the top.
So it came down and, like,
a full-on surplap, surplap!
And I was like -- saw stars.
I cracked a rib.
-No!
-My neck was all messed up.
Yeah.
And then, like, from there,
they pulled us out
and then they're like,
"Are you good?"
And I'm like, "I think so."
And they're like,
"Can you do that?"
And I'm like, "Uh..."
And they're like,
"You don't have a concussion.
You're good. Next race."
And I'm like...
-Wow!
-Yeah, and that's just
one of the episodes.
It truly was insane.
Rebel Wilson and I
did an action stunt episode.
-Reunited.
-Yeah, we were reunited.
And it feels so good.
And we always talk about how
we're known as comedy people,
but we want to be
some cool action heroes.
You know?
-All comedians
want to be James Bond.
-We all want to be something
we're obviously not.
And I'm like, "I'm a cool action
hero" and she's the same way.
And so I was like,
"We should do something
where we get to do
a ton of cool stunts."
And so she -- We're, like,
at a wild Western theme place,
and she like -- We get in a big
bar fight and she shoots me
and I run up the stairs
and I'm looking
for a way to escape
and she comes outside and she
shoots me from the street
and I fall like four stories
into some cardboard boxes,
and I told the stunt guys
this idea,
and they're like, "Cool,
so when you get up there,
we'll do a Texas switch
and you'll flip
with the real stunt guy
and he'll fall into the boxes."
I'm like, "No, that's the whole
point of the show
is I'm going to fall
onto the boxes.
And they're like, "Well, that's
a really bad idea,"
and I'm like, "Exactly!"
-That's the name of the show!
-"That's the name of the show!"
-I want to show --
-It's on Quibi now.
-I want to show a clip.
This is from the demolition
derby episode.
Take a look at this.
-Oh, cool.
-Slow down when we get into
the turns
because this thing can tip.
-All gas, no brake.
-What?
-No!
♪♪
-Now we're cooking, baby!
-Let's make a run
for the jewels.
♪♪
-Ugh.
-Hey, Adam, you good?
-I feel like I got hit
in the head with a baseball bat.
-We're okay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We didn't die!
-We had it too, boy.
-My thanks to Adam Devine.
Check out "Bad Ideas
with Adam Devine" on Quibi.
Chronixx performs for us next.
Stick around, everybody.
Good luck on
the wedding planning.
-Yeah, thanks, Jimmy.
See ya, man.